-Our first guest tonight i
a United States Senator
from Minnesota.
Her book "Antitrust:
Taking on Monopoly Power
from the Gilded Age
to the Digital Age"
is available now.
Please welcome back to the sho
Senator Amy Klobuchar.
Thank you so much
for being here, Senator.
-Hey, Seth, it's great to be on.
-So, I want to ask, last week,
you were in the room.
Obviously, a limited attendanc
for Biden's first big speech
Exciting for many people,
especially seeing two wome
on the dais behind him.
Maybe a little boring
for other people.
Senators Romney and Cruz
both caught dozing off.
How did you find the evening
-I actually thought
it was a very good speech.
It was such a different
environment,
a little less partisan, becaus
of standing up and down.
But I will say, no matter
who the president is,
before you go in there and watch
a long speech at 9:00 -- coffee.
-Yeah.
-But you can't drink too much.
You just drink a little.
So that might have helped.
But I think that Joe Biden -
-Yeah, that should be
one of the things they teach
newly elected officials,
insofar as how to deal
with a long speech.
-Yes.
-I want to ask about --
Certainly,
in the primary season,
both you and President Biden
were framed as moderates
in, you know, the very crowded
at the time, primary field
And yet it seems as though -
and certainly laid out
in that speech --
that a very progress agend
is being pursued.
How do you feel,
being a part of this,
and do you feel like
that's the way things are going?
-This is the moment
to get things done
for this country.
And I think the fact that we'v
had four years of neglect
of our democracy
and nothing done
on things like childcare
or really in a big way
on infrastructure,
people want change.
That's why they voted in Georgia
for two Democratic senators.
That's why Joe Biden won b
the big margin that he won by.
And so I don't think
it's a surprise
that he's doing well now and
that he's pursuing
this agenda,
and that while we have
a lot of differences
in our party,
we try to work it out.
And that's how we got
that rescue plan passed.
It was so important,
as you pointed out
in your openings there,
to get the vaccine numbers up,
to get the economy shored up
So I think
it's what people want.
I think it's
the right thing to do.
And our party,
we may have disagreements --
you see them on the news -
but we don't purge people
and try to kick them out
just because they're
telling the truth
like Liz Cheney.
-So it's very good timing for us
to have you on,
talking about
your antitrust book,
because so much happened,
even today.
For example, Facebook decide
to uphold their ban
on former President Trump,
to extend it
at least another six months.
What is your reaction
to that news?
-That was the right thing to do.
He's the dis-informer-in-chief
He told the biggest lie
of all time,
which led to an insurrection
by getting his followers
to believe that the election
was a fake.
It was an outrageous momen
with a number of Republicans
calling him out on it
at the time.
And so, as I said
on that inaugural stage,
this is the time
for our democracy
to pick itself up,
dust itself off, move forward.
And we do not need more
disinformation from Donald Trump
or, for that matter, from others
who are spreading disinformation
about the vaccine,
that's making people think
they're getting a microchi
planted in their shoulder,
like the guy I met at a café
who said his mother-in-law
wouldn't get it because
she read that on Facebook.
There has to be some rules o
the road in place.
And someone like him
shouldn't be allowed
to make people believe lies.
-So, you know, obviously,
this was a decision,
and this was based on rule
that Facebook has laid out
You know, this was not
government intervention
on the Donald Trump ban,
but I do think it speaks t
how powerful Facebook is
that a former president
is desperate to have
that platform back.
And we saw a lot of members of
the GOP today basically backin
this idea that you lay out
in your book, as far as,
like, it's important
to break up monopolies.
Yet they're not just angry
about the de-platforming
of Donald Trump,
but they also think
that tech is too "woke."
Do you see this now as a momen
where you might actually hav
some help from across the aisl
in taking steps
to, you know, sort of have
antitrust legislation?
Or do you think
it's just posturing
based on the fact
that they're angry today
about, you know, this decision
that was specific
to the former president?
-There is
some posturing going on.
And this notion they put out
there
that, "Oh, tech is bad
because liberals work there,
or something like that, that's
not the reason to move forward
The reason to move forward i
that we have a few companies
that are the biggest
the world has ever known,
that are gateways,
and make it really hard
for competition to come up
they buy everything in sight
Look at what just --
We had a hearing
on the app stores, with Google
and Apple in front of us,
and found out from companies
like Spotify, Tile,
and, yes, match.com
about how they have to pay 30%
of what people buy
on their app store sites,
and they have to give it
to Apple or Google.
They are told
that they can't even say,
"You can get a better deal
on our website."
This isn't good for competition.
And we've always been
an entrepreneurial country
that rejuvenates itself
with capitalism.
Small businesses emerge.
they do well,
they turn sometimes
into big businesses,
sometimes not.
But when you have a compan
that buys everything in sigh
and where its head,
Mark Zuckerberg,
literally sent an e-mail
that got discovered last year,
that said,
"We'd rather buy than compete,
that is Exhibit A of a monopoly.
And I wanted to make the cas
to the country.
We've seen this before.
We did something about it.
And we need to use our law
to do it again.
-Well, I think it's interestin
what you just said there,
because, obviously, big business
would frame antitrust
as being anti-capitalist.
But can you speak more
to the idea
that antitrust legislation
can help capitalism
because it evens
the playing field?
-There's all kinds of examples
of this through history.
Most notably,
the breakup of AT&T.
That brought us lower
long-distance rates.
I was representing MCI
a bit after this happened,
so I know a lot about it.
It also started
the cellphone industry up.
Those cellphones used to be th
size of Gordon Gekko's briefcase
in the movie "Wall Street.
And now we have
all kinds of options.
And the former chair of AT&T
himself has said
it made them a stronger compan
because they had to compete.
That's what we need to do again.
It may mean divesting assets
They don't need to own --
Facebook doesn't need to own
WhatsApp and Instagram.
Maybe those two companies
would have developed
better privacy policies or
misinformation policies,
and bells and whistles
we'll never know of.
But they ate them up, becaus
in Mark Zuckerberg's words
in a discovered e-mail,
"They could have been
disruptive to us."
Competition is about disruption.
I worked in the private sector
I believe in capitalism.
But I also know
that you have to have
a check and balance
to make sure
that we keep having new
competitive companies emerge
-You talk about -- and I don't
think it would be surprising -
most people, the first tim
they hear "monopoly"
is because of the board game
Right?
That's the first time
kids hear that word
and understand a little bi
of what it means.
You lay out the history
that's sort of unknown --
or not well-known,
I should say --
history of that board game
-Exactly.
And a woman named Lizzie Magie
who is not notable in histor
and was discovered
through some great reporting
from a "New York Times"-
"Wall Street Journal" reporter
she actually
came up with the idea.
She was strongly against
monopolies.
Then, what happens is,
Mr. Darrow and Parker Brothers
come in,
and guess what,
for the first time in history,
a man got credit
for a woman's idea.
[ Laughter ]
-That was it.
And then other men
were like, "That's great.
We should keep doing that.
-"Let's keep doing it."
-This has been pointed out
by a number of people --
your colleague,
Secretary of Transportation now,
Pete Buttigieg, he had a boo
that just came out
called "Trust."
And people were wondering
if "Antitrust" was
a counter to that.
But you want to
lay those rumors to rest.
-I do.
The rivalry does not continue.
In fact, I actually
did an interview
with his book behind me
at one point to promote it
We're good friends.
I met his dogs recently.
We had lunch, went on a walk
He's a great guy.
He's doing a really good job
But one thing I have
that Pete doesn't have --
I have over 100 cartoons
in my book, Seth, yes.
-Alright, well, again,
so if you're a kid at home
looking for the book to buy,
this one has cartoons and
a backstory about Monopoly
Speaking about meeting dogs,
have you ever met Major?
Have you met
the president's dog?
[ Laughter ]
-No, I have not.
-Okay. Well, maybe.
-I don't know how --
I heard Major -
didn't he go to Delaware
to be with his family
for a while?
-Yeah,
that's what they tell you.
[ Laughter ]
That's another thing
they tell kids about.
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
We really appreciate it.
"Antitrust" is available now